son imposant de toiture ne passe pas
inaperçu l'hôtel dieu et bien l'endroit
touristique incontournable de la ville
un peu plus loin la fosse dionne
s'offrent aux touristes
cette famille des alentours de tonnerre
vient régulièrement avec plaisir visiter
ou revisiter cette source alimenté en
permanence
audrey vite à paris elle veut maintenant
faire découvrir au plus grand nombre
l'eau turquoise qui a baigné son enfance
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit un peu
mystérieux quand j'étais petit
voilà ça me faisait rêver et maintenant
je viens la filmer en 360 pour essayer
de montrer un peu au monde la fosse
dionne est de faire connaître la pause
yonne et j'espère que de nombreux
touristes vont venir pour découvrir cet
endroit ville très charmante un charme
que tonnerre veut continuer de faire
fructifier
il faut avoir l'oeil pour le remarquer
mais les panneaux d'entrée de ville
signale que cette commune de plus de
5000 habitants fait depuis peu partie du
réseau de petites cités de caractère
ce label est décerné à de petites
communes dotées d'un bâti architectural
de qualité ces communes s'engage en
contrepartie à le mettre en valeur
auprès des habitants et des visiteurs
dans le cadre donc des petites cités de
caractère nous avons créé un fonds
petite cité de caractère qui permet à
l'ensemble des propriétaires sur le
secteur sauvegardé d'avoir des fonds
disponibles pour améliorer donc les
toitures les façades de faire de la
rénovation donc ça c'est un atout
économique puisque ça met en avant la
possibilité à des artisans de travailler
et de rénover un autre bâti et des
curiosités tonnerre ne manquent pas
si ce label met en avant le caractère
monumental du patrimoine il vise aussi
le patrimoine culturel comme dans cet
hôtel particulier qui accueille les
collections de la ville et recèle de
belles histoires
notamment celle du chevalier d'éon ici
vous avez une gravure de cet homme
illustre un très très connu hors des
frontières françaises
mais et qui mériterait tout à fait de
retrouver sa place au centre de la ville
et ce label petite cité de caractère
c'est justement promouvoir tous les
éléments qui permettront demain à
tonnerre pas de reprendre sa place dans
l'histoire de france et aussi dans le
coeur des français tonnerre est à ce
jour la seule ville de bourgogne franche
comté à être inscrits dans ce réseau